yeah what's going on man chimenti Dean
Edwards and we are in the building once
again once again in song it's good to be
back be back here fly solos been a
second had a lot of guests in the last
last couple of weeks in the last month
or so some interesting guess uh who I
proceed we want to send a special shout
out to all things County and some of our
comedy mates in all things you know uh
big up to uh belly bar and I'll magical
running a wonderful operation over there
all things comedy um yeah make sure you
keep if you're in LA keep an eye out for
all things coming live at The Comedy
Store I think the day after my birthday
on George gent chick judges I forgot my
birthday one on July thirty-first
failure y'all make sure if you're in LA
go by it's gonna be a gonna be a great
show and always check out us some of our
friends that arrives that have shows or
no thinks comedy network I'm in in
Edwards and soccer comic grand Dean Del
Rey let that beat all Brian uh Brian
scolaro is my prize this is my podcast
you know um who has a dope junk uh John
I just said that like I'm from Philly
had a dope Joan Tom Rhodes Tom Rhodes
radio Tom Rose always funny dude he's
like the official of the most official
Road Dogg um and uh a lot of uh you know
funny cats I'm air you why do you want
to check them out you know what's been
going on with me well um can I just say
we are we're smack dab in the middle of
heat wave 2015 this uh this is the first
is the first official blaze of the
season bed I of you know what I was
fortunate enough last
winter that's always weird when you say
last because you always want to say this
winter because the new winter which is
approaching saying uh what when's winter
begin I guess in I know is it December
would you say november december the
winter solstice I'm not sure uh but I
always look at it as well this winter
realistically in my mind because I look
at the calendar year so I'm like this
winter that just passed so this past you
know january-february March even parts
of April when it was cold that should be
this winter in my mind that's how I
always thought about it but in actuality
I've learned that this winter is the
approaching winter since we're in the
middle of the summer it's what's coming
versus what already happened what
already happened is last winter or this
pass when I'm sorry I'm sorry that's
it's really this is going nowhere and
it's going nowhere fast people ahahaha
but of y'all is hot Sun and what's
what's interested it's hot but it's
still mild in comparison to recent uh
summer times where it's been you know in
the hundreds so I'm not going to really
complain because we're only at about
ninety one but if you hear a humming in
the background no it's not a do rock
group it's the fan that I'm sitting in
front of because is that John blaze
apologies that this episode is coming at
you I'll a wee bit later than that
expected a brother was was running
running around uh you know in the last
couple of days and I wasn't able to get
the pod casts out to you the listeners
to the fam um you know so for that I
apologize that it's coming to you late
but it's coming to you nonetheless be
happy with it why am I speak again this
was why why
you I think everything goes down a lot
smoother when it comes from a British
accent if you say things with a British
accent people just Revere it hold it in
higher esteem do you understand what I'm
saying yes it's so say for instance if
you're angry with someone and you say
you've really pissed me off they still
or if you cuss someone out if you say if
I say duck my sick father Maku you see
what I just did there let's let this
lesser cussin I just dis let's dyslexic
us to out duck my sick for the mucker
have you said vs. with the mild British
accent took my sick father Makka you
know you've offended someone yet you've
made them feel special hole in one
sentence have you save in say Gandalf
town don't buy [ __ ] for Ibaka fly you
from fri then they'll think you just
cast a spell on them that's what will
happen I'm uh I'm being silly because I
missed you did you miss me how was your
week my week was fabulous you know what
um it's funny because I was gone for a
couple of weeks and anytime I'm going
for for a couple of weeks I always feel
like here I have to get back in the in
the mode of family time so I gotta spend
more time with the family and put the
phone down does this happen any of you
do you uh well I'll get back to that and
put the phone down and disconnect from
the matrix even though you feel inclined
to me on your phone or your social media
or your or your laptop or your tablet I
wanted to say ipad which I just did so
that kind of negates what I was just
trying to do or just attempting to do I
wanted to say tablet to to show respect
towards all tablets and not just iPad
take that mr. jobs um yeah uh so usually
when i get home i like to just chill
with me for me for the matter of a few
days a couple of days um but last last
Wednesday you know what I did know what
I did I uh I was talking to our buddy
mr. Harris Stanton who um who I will I
will have on soon but whenever you know
I'm but maybe we'll do another episode
next time we're on the road together
because you know obviously harris rd
tracy and probably even the liberal bad
driver um you know they all have settled
with with walmart and and they're all
here mainly they're all here they're all
healthy rest in peace uncle jimmy mack
and condolences as always to his family
but i believe everyone's been
financially compensated by walmart and
so being that harrah's now is back on
stage everyone's been rushing to do
these interviews with him and as my
friend so I think he and I we were
talking one day in the car and he was uh
he was he was saying now we were talking
about my podcast and then I said oh you
know what you got to come back not even
on some here you gotta come back because
you were in his car accident and that's
news I really just was like you know it
has been a while since we tossed it up
in Harris has a nice refreshing
perspective in comparison and stark
contrast to mine so it'd be good to
happen but he said he promised I think
he promised uh luis gomez that he would
do their their podcast Legion of skanks
so y'all y'all gonna check out Harrison
Legion the skanks and I think he also
did a genus savages former former
manager of a couple of comedy clubs
Boston comedy club most notably and also
Broadway comedy club owned by one almaty
um yes so uh so the inherent says a man
of his word you gotta respect that
as a man was worried he said how you
know what I promised Louis I'd uh do his
first so I said I know if I said well
we'll just do do mine whatever so um so
we were talking last week and he tells
me that they are actually he's part of
the big Jay roast at the creek in the
cave out in Long Island City I didn't
know where it was I didn't I honestly
didn't even know big Jay was being
roasted until I think I saw a post maybe
on facebook and then I was like wait
harris's on it doesn't way I was no
about roasting somebody huh what does
hair is know about Rosen somebody um but
I said you know let me go ahead and
investigate and we'll we'll uh we'll see
how it how it's going and that's what we
did so we we went to check it out we
rolled with him Harris Harris is now
driving what is it called I'll probably
mess it up uh uh hair Harris has is hey
Harris Harris has his is wearing his
walmart of buddy or I think Keith
Robinson told told bark theobald um he
told mark like he's he's gonna be broke
by februari uh yeah yeah so he's he said
how he's gonna be broke but Eric
actually and in all honesty Harris's is
not uh is not blowing is his paper which
which I'm happy to see he's uh he's
enjoying himself which is what you do
but he's not he's not overdoing it
however he does have a nice new uh Audi
is it Audi's 78 I don't know you you can
tell a brother that knows nothing about
cars does he have a UH an Audi iphone 7
g s like when you want to impress
somebody with cars just add letters and
numbers yeah I'm on a Jaguar ZX
43 it sounds fast done it so Harris uh
Harris he he comes to what his was funny
this fool this wool he hits me I hit him
on wednesday because i had a bunch of
running around doing wednesday so i get
home wednesday evening around six I'm
like you know what time should I be
ready and he's like he's like oh man I
gotta be there around seven-thirty it
starts at eight you know I like getting
in early um why'd you need a ride do I
need a ride negro let me explain
something I've been picking you up for
the better part of one and a half
decades for since probably what 2,000
maybe 2002 2003 I school Paris up you're
coming to pick me up heresy any was he
wasn't beefing about it so he came
scooped brother up um I just say that's
a nice a nice it is a nice vehicle you
know they it has this holographic uh is
very futuristic which is funny because
when you think of someone just told me
my sister-in-law just told me she was
watching army i think it was back to the
future part two which was the one where
they went to the future I think back to
the future was the one where they went
forward in time and Biff was this uh was
his millionaire multi-millionaire
because he he had all the dates from
from the sports book and so he bet on a
bunch of sporting events and became rich
and uh so anyway my sister-in-law
totally unnecessary information to help
the story move along but I like filling
in the details can you blame me he's on
my my sister-in-law she's uh she's
telling me um how she was watching back
to the future too and it's get peep the
job it took place in thi think the movie
was made what
saying 1985-86 and the movie took place
in 2015 when they went to the future
which is now so according to steven
spielberg and whoever else helped create
the back to future franchise they
thought we were going to have
hoverboards we weren't we wouldn't be on
skateboards we'd be on hoverboards and
we be in tight jeans so they're kind of
there they kind of a date they
overthought it a little bit but um you
we do have segways hmm we have segways
um we don't have hoverboards but we have
we have Tony Hawk mmm Tony Hawk uh and
and black men wearing skinny jeans so
you can see how we kinda he kind of was
in the vicinity of where the future
should have been we always those movies
always did have us thinking like the
future was going to be so farm beyond
what we what we actually have in the
future but there are some things that
did parallel say for instance uh on the
original Star Trek Captain Kirk's
Captain Kirk had a flip phone Captain
Kirk and the crew of the starship
enterprise they were rocking a motorola
flip phones back in 1968-69 um yes so I
just think that's I think that's pending
presence so anyway Ariza's card has I'm
really don't need to go on and on about
Harris's fly ride but it's a nice
vehicle uh it has this like hologram
where the speed limit instead of you
having to look down at the dashboard the
speed limit is displayed right on the UH
in this is like a hologram that's
projected onto the windshield i think is
dump site and then if you have the gps
program that also shows you the arrows
and directions you're supposed to turn i
thought it's got I so we go we get out
there
and here's was funny this dude who's
never never I don't know if harris's
ever owned the car he definitely never
owned a brand-new car let alone a brand
new luxury car but one thing Harris is
always one issue I've always noticed is
when I'm driving and he's the passenger
whether we're in New York City or on the
road but especially in the greater
metropolitan area of New York City this
dude does not like traffic he doesn't
like traffic or congestion and he lets
you know he's like [ __ ] man what the
hell what's going on this traffic and I
don't know why I just sounded like Todd
when I said that but uh but this duty
really gets frustrated so we we drove to
uh he picked me up and then we drove to
a long island city I had never been to
the creek in the cave I didn't realize
it was in Long Island City lawyer long
island city has changed drastically no
longer do you see prostitutes walking
around on the streets as as back in the
days now now it's yo is gentrified long
island city is the original Williamsburg
and or the original uh Brooklyn because
I remember going long on the city for
those that are not from New York City
and don't understand the layout of New
York City Long Island City uh how can I
describe long island city is right next
to Queensbridge right I and if anyone
knows Queens bridge projects from music
they know that's where nas nasir Jones
nas is from the rapper that's where Mobb
Deep is from that's where the original
juice crew all stars from roxanne shante
MC Shan I think Craig gee I think masta
ace is from Brooklyn but a lot a lot of
legends of shooting
now I was gonna say Capone Noriega but
they're from left Rack City home oh yes
y'all should know my my hip hop
knowledge is got a thorough Sun hit her
head but I'm get so these these places
are right next to each other so to see
all these luxury condos and and gourmet
coffee shops in this little greenwich
village right next right across Queen
across a queensboro bridge which I guess
splits there's queensboro bridge is like
eight mile in uh in the movie or is it
seven miles divides between I don't
remember I don't know enough about
Detroit if there's my boy CP but leaving
Spanky but I think eight mile is the
divider that splits the good side of the
city versus the bad side of city and
that's kind of what queensboro bridge is
the 59th Street bridge splits off we're
Queens bridge projects are from long
island city and long island city is uh
it was popping that it was it was was
very busy late at night so they had the
bad the big Jay roast now here's what
what I found interesting as we walk up
as we roll up we see John Moses is
interviewing I think Dan Soder uh and we
bum rush the interview and I guess the
interview is to accompany the
forthcoming roast of ron jeremy i did
not know that while working on one roast
they're preparing for another roast
that's already in the can i guess so
they start interviewing they decide that
our job decides he wants to interview
Harrison myself so he's interviewing us
about the first time we we saw ron
jeremy and i think my first time i
mentioned it was when you'd like you
know your first your first porno movies
were were horrific they were bad
right let's be honest like they were bad
but they were good for their time but if
you look at what what we uh what was
exciting back then versus now I mean
still make it his neck and you know sex
is sex but now the things they do in
comparison oh the talents i must say
they really progressed haven't they
though he's interviewing us and then he
says um he asked somebody who's like you
now are a few are you familiar with Lisa
am I don't know no lisa ann like does
lisa ann know me I don't know no lisa
ann is i was like he doesn't know who
these hannah's and i run off a bunch of
vixens that i am familiar with you know
say an obsession a luscious lopez a who
else obsession luscious lopez pinky of
course roxy reynolds ah jazmine cashmere
applause to you jasmine she's retired
doubt um and the reason I know that is
because uh from Chicago and who was it i
think not Chicago home is it wasn't
jaydeep you know what Deon Cole Deon
Cole or JD I think it was Dianna know he
we were discussing adult actresses some
of our faves and he was like yeah nah
man she retires she back in Chicago I
was like ah too bad for her but good for
good for you boo um so I know Lisa was
so interview where well we you know we
exchanged pleasantries to a bunch of
comics hadn't seen in a while some
industry Maureen Terran used to be with
new way almost had had her as a manager
when a different route but it was great
seeing her she looked good slim down
nice not that she was ever a heavy uh
big J cleans up nicely can I just say
that big J does killing up nicely be
cute I told him I said hey man you have
the exact Zander Vanderpool look that
the boys to men uh first ran with in in
motown philly back in the mid 92 93 he
uh he was rocking the blazer with the
tie with the pocket square with the
denim but still had on dirty boots you
gotta love them and and cut the hair see
we we are we we create the trench people
I cut my hair Jake cut his hair because
that's what we do we don't need long
hair we we we set the trend let y'all
jump on it and then kept it moving why
is my face squid it up like it is right
now I have no idea anyway so the roast
Rose was actually great just went a
little too now I went a lot to lausanne
that Rose was was it went forever
forever ever forever ever and a day that
John lasted way too long because there's
the thing when you're roasting I look
I'm not some roaster but I know there
are time constraints for a reason and
you should you know you do do a couple
of minutes and keep it moving they were
and there they were probably at least
three or four too many people on the
days and if each person is doing
ten-plus minutes that just makes for a
long night it started at eight that
joint didn't end till after eleven at
least damn it was long um notable
highlights I gotta say Irish did a great
job I and more than great job because he
did his time and kept it moving he
wasn't up there if he was up there five
minutes I'd be surprised uh as a matter
fact people were doing like 15 I think
mike vecchione probably did the longest
mike vecchione Ari Shaffir who else
mark Normand kept it kept it pretty
short but uh yeah Becky and Becky was
killing don't get me wrong Becky was
killing re from what I saw he did well i
just i had to get outside it was hotter
than that man a little uncomfortable um
but but Becky had pages and pages and
great jokes and I know it sucks to write
so many jokes and have to edit and
whittle down but you gotta Whittle down
kitties for all you for all your new
Jack's out there that are listed this
week's protocol is as follows here when
roasting someone the kiss method is
necessary me say that again when
necessary keep it simple stupid or keep
it short and simple but just just keep
it moving man it was too long and I
think because his would happen I think
like was using Vecchione as an example
and the only reason I use it as an
example I even told him I said yeah it
was you did you think somebody was just
dumb long I think he started off and was
blah Blau killing and then I think
people people got exhausted because they
were like oh he's still going because
they seeing you turning pages and
realizing yo this is going on wait
longer than uh than I expected and we
still have to get through eight more
people you know that's my little two
cents uh but aside from that it was a
fun night yeah it was a fun night and
always great seeing people who else I
saw wing rakha there's a traitor wayne
used to uh he actually managed Patrice
for a little bit he also ran Boston
comedy club for a while under Barry cats
when Barry still owned it still had it
uh
guess so a bunch of just always always
good being at those types of events
because it's nice seeing people you
haven't seen in a long time and uh yeah
yeah oh you know it saw Michael che it's
always good his was funny che and I we
we don't see each other a lot but when
he's we see each other we always always
toss it up um about SNL and you don't
catch up you know he catches me up to
things I I sort of uh give him my
insight from when I was there and he
laughs and smiles because he realizes
how I it hasn't changed so hasn't
changed in 40 years so has changed its
evolved but there's certain things that
are still instituted and in place that
have remained which which is why the
show is a television history and why it
works and Lauren Lauren's figured out a
formula that some people may not agree
with but a it works for him and works
for everyone that has worked there you
know no um yeah so we caught it up
congrats to che uh because uh he just
got got his contract renewed and here's
the thing a lot of people don't know
right around early to mid July is when
people begin to get renewed on their
contracts for the following season so he
got his but the awkward the awkward
feeling is you kind of lay low because
people start making those calls yo did
you uh did you hear anything yet you
hear anything yet and it's awkward when
you've got renewed and someone calls you
like yeah what what what happened have
you heard anything yet I heard anything
like uh yeah they called but um but you
know I got renewed but you give her new
to that's all you can really say Amy
keep your head up
and don't worry we're all be back there
in eight ancient on the seventeenth
floor I can't wait to start writing some
new sketches so much is going on in the
news and we're looking forward to it you
know as I that's what you want is a butt
party is like ah damn cuz you can you
can you want to celebrate and you
celebrate that you got renewed but you
also alike man I hope my boy oh my girl
gets read up to but you never know when
you have I think he said that they have
a like 15 cast members to and having
experienced 15 cast member stretching at
one point I think it was 16 that's a lot
16 people across about 65 maybe 60 to 65
minutes worth the show a lot of show to
go around then you just when you
subtract the musical acts and we can
update is really you really only get
what about 40 to 45 minutes of show / 15
different people plus a host that has to
squeeze their face and mug into any and
everything that's on the show to show
that there are dumped triple threat they
can act dance and sing so I'm congrats
to Shay and I told them I said we'll
look man you gotta also appreciate that
uh you know you're living in an
unprecedented time for error on the show
where there there are five k 5 black
cast members you know between himself
and Pharaoh Leslie Keenan and shishir
that's five that's five Negroes that's a
beautiful thing and you hope that they
don't cancel each other out but I also
know the show so I fingers crossed that
all five are renewed you gotta figure
Leslie pop last year so she's definitely
in changes got renewed he pop I told him
I said you you're the first brother we
can update and you're doing
good job from the episodes i've seen so
you were getting renewed so you got
renewed Leslie I'm sure definitely
renewed and then you have what uh
Pharaoh came in and sheer Kenan I'm sure
if he wants to be there you can be there
because he has visibility and celebrity
because he's been on there the longest
has been on there since what Oh 3 so
that's uh this is this will be his going
insist 13th year if he decides to stay
and you're competing he might want to
just stage it just to beat out uh
Darrell Hammond as far as
longest-running cast members I think Tim
Meadows had it at one point and then
Darrell took over that and then uh King
has a chance to surpass that so um yeah
so your fingers crossed for uh I think
they'll all be back fer forge a and
shishir but I think they all do enough
so Tracy used to search you got you need
two episodes to justify your existence
and like I said I don't catch the show
enough but I do believe that they the
couple episodes I've seen they all
they've all they want me in a screen
time so that's that's that's a beautiful
thing um so yeah so the gross was cool
boom also check this out so then Friday
night Friday night speaking of smut and
porn I'm at new york comedy club they
asked me to uh white up doing the late
show too so I stick around and big up to
a millio and crew because they really
helped turn around to your comedy club
they're doing their best to give some
some good shows and present strong
comics along with newer cats too and
just making a nice hang out hey cuz
that's the thing big comics just want to
tell jokes and hang out right and so I
never understood when clubs had this
approach that they
make it this challenge and miss this
gatekeeper situation where they want
comics begging them and kissing the ring
and gasping and fighting for see you
want to fight for that stage time but
there's a respectful way to do it in my
opinion and i think i'm right and i know
i am so anyway i am waiting and waiting
to go on and they say oh you know what i
want to do the the pain or paid show
something huh yeah I whatever like yeah
you know uh you know Lisa and the porn
star I said you know that's funny you're
the second person in two days she's
hosting I said get out of here I said
really that's hilarious as a joke yo
does crazy we were just talking about
her two days ago and now she's
co-hosting this uh show so like I boo my
god no I'll go stick my head in i'll do
a guest spot on this uh this this what
sounds like a freaky show show I go in
there comic is on and son is giving a
son seminar on silence you go at it I
don't know his day and he might have
been funny I couldn't really hear what
he was saying i just i know people
weren't laughing and they explained to
me that paid or played paid or pain
means that if he did the comic does well
the the crowd will chair and say not
paid and that comic will get paid for
their stage time but if they caught a el
at the bomb they get sent on their way
and there they had a dominatrix sitting
on stage with them and she was there and
sure enough she was there waiting with
uh with hot wax candles to drip on his
chest did she whacks him did she I don't
think she ripped
his skin off his off his chest but it
was just a hot wax treatment I told
Harris about this later he was a man out
of bombed on purpose is it idiot yes so
uh so years old then they flogged they
fly the female comic she she actually
did well from what I saw but they
spanked her um in a dress she was
wearing a dress wow this just got very
perverse very very quickly I studied uh
went into my sexy voice I was just
saying but hey you know your watches are
what specs of us booty you're gonna
watch the jiggle uh voice and I rich
boys and i are watching like what what
happened what happened what has happened
to comedy what happened remember when
you you bombed on stage and you just
went home and cried in the mirror and
then worked your material and either
returned in a couple of months or went
to a smaller club to work your act until
you got up the courage to go back to
that club and show your face now they're
they're whipping and beating and waxing
comics anything for stage time I suppose
because as a matter of fact when I went
on stage I didn't even I didn't get to
Joe I was talking about the whole
situation from the dominatrix that's
that was sitting on stage while I was on
stage as well two of two having a
pornstar co-host the show I was funny in
lisa ann was was very uh very cool very
down to earth um yeah you know it was
funny since she since she's doing this
comedians podcast tour made me wonder is
this someone that that you all would
like to hear on the father Malcolm
protocol um you all let me know cuz she
actually found out she was giving out
dvds um I said you know what Harris
would like one of these since we were
just talking about it I thought it'd be
a funny thing to get she was
autographing them Seattle I'd she that
which you appreciate anyone that does
the pictures and
giveaways to the fans that are waiting
patiently in line but it also may be one
that was like geez that's got to be
weird how how how does that feel that
everywhere you go everyone has seen you
not only naked but seeing you do things
seen you do some things that you might
not want to tell your parents about
they've seen they've seen you gape how
about that thinks they've seen you gay
they've seen your your your sorry to
paint this picture but they've seen your
rectal cavity violated and gaping wide
open house how's that for painting a
picture did you all enjoy that boys and
girls yeah oh send all your comments
that I am Dean Edwards ah soo umm yeah
that's I because you gotta think I I
know him cuz you got to be thinking I'm
thinking that she's thinking all right
after the show I'm gonna have people
wait in line sign pictures of this uh
DVD with me naked on the cover with a
bunch of my girlfriends that also uh
porn actresses I think I've discussed
that before what's the difference
between a porn star in a store porn
actress something that if i do have her
on the father Malcolm protocol we will
we'll delve deeper into did you like
that choice of verbiage that I just used
did you did you um so yeah so I'm
wondering is she sitting there thinking
geez is she thinking I was gonna be
awesome because I know after so I'm
usually amped to meet meet and greet but
i also am not thinking everyone that's
coming up to me let alone anyone's
coming up to me is thinking oh I would I
want to see you naked I've seen you
naked and I want to see you naked again
where's with our you gotta think that's
all that the majority of people are
thinking no no one's in there like well
you know she's made me feel really
wonderful and got started I just
like as a person it also it's gotta be
creepy maybe maybe a little skeevy to
her cuz she had security though you can
leave the to see the large Negro and one
was large brother and one was I think
large Latino brother and they definitely
were there to make sure the line kept
flowing rather smoothly and yeah so um
and so as I went to get Harris's DVD uh
she said oh oh my god would you mind if
I fanned out right night now can I get a
picture I like oh man that just made my
day I had a porn star and when they take
a picture with me me donkey Dean uh-huh
so it was yeah that was that was kind of
cool that that uh that made my ego swell
along with a couple other things I all
pal zingy I'll be here all week try the
veal tip your waitstaff but not over
yeah so that was a ho was a fun week and
I think they do that show once a month
so um needless to say uh I'll be back
probably um yeah I think I'll be back I
most definitely will do that show again
the shows like that are fun because you
get to just sort of while out like a
nick cannon show you get to while it out
get it um so the rest of the weekend
rest weekend was cool did I start a
topic and not finish it did I not land
the plane properly I saw minions the
other day fun movie I'm actually way by
I don't know on my uh my summer moving
you know how like in school you had
summer reading well I have movies to see
so that's called summer moving I still
haven't seen terminator genisys nor
ant-man actually a good about what we
sub because they're too I'm the type of
dude when I Drive past the movie marquee
I liked to have seen at least thirty
percent or more of the movies that are
in the marquee usually when I'm when
when I've seen fifty percent I feel good
and when I've seen all the movies which
is very rare because there's always some
some movie like The Fault beyond our
stores playing where I'm i definitely
won't catch me watching that when it's
on regular TV let alone painter I won't
even sneak into a movie like that you
gotta be this it's just it's I'm I am
NOT the demographic which they are
seeking and I'm fine with that you know
um so yeah I gotta see a couple more
movies Harris told me a man was good he
said terminator genisys was dope and uh
you know what I would like come I you
know getting some interaction want you
to tell me what do y'all want to hear
more of would you know all people that
listen the fam that that Duff listen to
the following protocol and support and
because i don't think a lot of people
peeped the Rodney Laney episode the way
they should have I was actually I go for
a little disappointed in y'all me you
know watch out y'all down like a proper
no more well I'm I ain't bringing it
ain't green I ain't bringing the Thunder
the way the way I like like me to bring
the Thunder let a brother know uh cuz
that that you know y'all have a control
and saying and what I'm doing on it too
because yellow y'all offense but I you
know their peaks and valleys because at
one point I said well you know maybe the
the [ __ ] Road Warrior sessions aren't
things that people want to hear and I
hope y'all don't listen based on who's
famous and who isn't who you're familiar
with in who you are because i'm not
going to interview a sit-down with
someone who I don't think is uh not
interesting like that's to me that's
what was gonna make me want to sit down
with someone whether or not they're
interesting whether it's uh you know
Rodney slay me last week to Jenna bring
on the week before or the area of the
week before royale we
what ad I'm they all they all have a
different journey a different different
insight that they can offer to to the
game to this thing called comedy man so
yeah y'all y'all get at me whether you
listen consistently or you just happen
to be turning on for the first time and
he said oh you know what that dude with
the bat he looks interesting who's he
about to hit what is the father buckin
protocol I'm gonna listen to it if you
listen let a brother know uh what you
thinking and what you'd like the air or
who you'd like to hear interviews wise
like I said I like thinking outside of
the box and getting people that not
everybody else is necessarily rushing to
uh to interview I want to get my boy
Jason and O's on air Rosie's uh you know
it beat up actually uh boss not a thing
of it rich voice because I think that's
I go I think I'm like my future my
upcoming guests that have expressed
interest in doing the show Judah
Friedlander the champion the world champ
Judah Friedlander pop popping Keith
fudging Robinson will will will will uh
ask him what Putnam is for and why it
was on a headshot back in the days and
there was someone else Keith Judah I
know he said um fudge ah man I can't
think of it from Friday oh man are you
kidding me big worm I was Shu Fang on I
was like there was an F in his name
Faison and a couple other people had in
mind but Jason and or is definitely on
that list because uh he'd be a great
great addition because he has a b-boy
background coming up with rock steady
crew but also rich Voss because
rich is one of the first white comics
that came up doing the black rooms and
and did both rooms you know and found
success doing both room so I'd love to
have have Richard one Richard Voss on
the show you know to see you see what
it's been like for him but I think
that's enough for this week because I
want to get this out the UH wouldn't get
this out to you as quickly as possible
baby once again I apologize for getting
too late a day late and a dollar short
but a day late still means you got it
yard so yeah just kidding 50 cent um
someone told me they want me to do more
impressions on the show so I guess I'm
doing them all right here then the show
I get out I keep seeing Paul Giamatti
I've got to do something with this
impression told um I just haven't
figured it out yet you know for media
presents are like a like a math problem
right um you just gotta keep working at
it eventually you will figure it out so
it'll it'll it'll come just gotta
believe in it it'll come just let it
come come sooner than later it will
trust in me trust didn't Jesus he can
make alone right do you fear death
that's from a show what is that live
them do you fear death more than you
vary from a cartoon it's not the GoBot
something from the 80s do you fear death
more than you fear be and it's not it's
not the Thunder Thunder Thundercats ho I
don't know it's it's it's not necessary
for me to uh to recall exactly where
that episode or what TV show that was
that uh I used to watch that had that
why don't you all go search it google it
do you
fear death more than you fear me and let
me know what you come up with witcha oh
you know what else uh I'm uh back on my
back on my back on my meds heavy but not
by man's I made my meditation you see
what I did back there man back on my
meditation Eveleigh this is a video that
always watch one when I'm feeling like I
want to be you know sort of motivated
and and it's by I didn't realize who
then the narration was it was a someone
spliced together this uh this football
players work out with this motivational
speaker the speaker's name I just
learned his name is Eric Thomas he's a
former professional football player I
played I think nine seasons with the
Cincinnati Bengals and the New York Jets
and denver broncos but dude has this uh
as this uh this mattre mantra that he
lives by uh when you want success as bad
as you want to breathe they then you'll
be successful did i say that right i
think i said that right when you wanted
when you wanted it bad right is that it
am successful successful when you want
it as badly i guess i could google it
right all right i could google it and
look it up so well here look at that
kingsdown it Malcolm X is dead quick
greatness is upon you you better act
like it you talk talks about his being
homeless when you when you want to
succeed as bad as you want to breathe
that's when you be successful that's the
line which is a dope line dope line when
you want when you want to succeed as bad
as you want to breathe that's when
you'll be successful that's the that's
the challenge that I think many of us
could pose upon ourselves to move
forward in life and I'm actually I've
been really focused on one
me and breathing reading words into a
reality in you know making making the
word I taking the power in the word I
and letting it manifest and when I say I
mean the capital letter I as an i will I
I can be what I will to be that's us
from a from Charles F I Nels the
universal what is it the keys I'm real
bad at that's why I don't read a lot
that's why I don't tell people I read a
lot because some people are good at just
pulling off and rambling off titles of
books and the authors the master key
system Charles by Charles have handled
the master key system in charge with
Charles let me say that like I was doing
a voiceover the master key system by
Charles F canal I just spit on myself a
good book and it talks about using the
word I and talking about what you do
have versus what you want talk about
what you want talk about what is talk
about what you what you have what what
you will have make it make it your
reality that you already do have
something already you know these are
things that you apply you use the power
of your subconscious mind to to succeed
you know and then when you want that
means you are lacking or something is
absent and there's a deficiency versus
having which means you possess and you
hold and you get and you receive and
experience so you wanna you want to have
versus want you know so um yeah maybe
I'll drop drop some uh some jewels on
y'all every so often huh good do that
can I continue with that you know cuz
you're not Leia you Matthew you know I
do anyway this has been wheels been fun
it's always fun it's therapeutic
and uh anyone that that once do I you
know like i said i suggest you want to
read a good book that that i've read in
the past and it's a book that has a
lessons and actually it's not a book you
read directly through check out the
master key system in 24 parts with
questionnaire and glossary unabridged
original edition by charles f Crennel a
good book i probably refer to his book
every i'm probably reread this book
every two or three years maybe maybe
something you want to read every year
because uh 24 chapters and you only read
one chapter and each chapter is
relatively short but there's a there's
an exercise at the end of every every
chapter and I always find it uh it
assists with my meditation and my comic
and finding my Center and allowing my
energy to flow properly so uh anyone
that wants to join me um hit a brother
up let me know I yo as always a big up
all things comedy now make sure you go
in the follow all things comedy on
social media follow me at I am the Dean
Edwards I am in that was because you
know what it is that's who I in all love
I've catch up next week yeah be well and
make sure I remember to talk about Judd
Apatow's book which I'm also even sick
in the head by the jet out of town fun
book
actually very reminiscent of Franklin a
JS comic insight the various very
similar obviously Apatow has Hollywood
by the nude sec wait so here's some
popular but for those that want on
another good book and when I hear about
people the crisis stand-up comics
process and you know what I'll try and
remember to mention it earlier podcast
next week but Franklin a je was it
Franklin today comic in sight good boy
all right all love y'all two fingers
people